welcome back y'all i'm hanging out with
tony gonzalez and josh brolin give it up
later this week i turned the big 4-0
but instead of doing too much
celebrating of myself i want to
celebrate others and things that are
near and dear to my heart one of those
things is reading do you all love
reading you're all big readers love love
too
the escapism alone um so you may
remember i started a reading initiative
this year this idea is so simple y'all
strangers recommend books to other
strangers it could be someone at a
coffee shop a park even online we call
it stranger reads
[Music]
you better sing
80s chick jesse after our first stranger
reads segment thousands of you took to
the comments to recommend books i was so
blown away i also matched two people in
my audience who exchanged their
favorites they are back with us now so
please welcome haley and kevin
just to recap y'all had never met each
other and you'd never read these books
right right okay so what do you think
what ended up happening yeah so kevin
gave me one of his favorite books last
by andrew sean greer and i normally
don't read books like this i read a lot
of fantasy and female-centered stories
but this is about a gay man who travels
the world and goes on this journey of
self-discovery and i was pleasantly
surprised i really loved this book i
really related to the message that not
everyone anyone in life has a set path
and
there's always time to discover yourself
and establish yourself and it was just
so comforting to be reassured that i
don't need to always know what i want to
do in life and that i don't need to take
life so seriously all the time and i
feel like i read it at the perfect time
and kevin just told me that there's a
sequel coming out and i'm really excited
to get to read that soon so oh that's
awesome
um kevin what about you yeah so haley
gave me an ember in the ashes by someone
to hear it's a young adult fantasy book
um young adult generally isn't a genre i
gravitate towards so um going into this
i didn't really know what to expect but
haley said
this book was the first time
that she felt represented and to me
being gay finding representation and
stuff like that is so important so i
knew this like this was going to be
special
um and i ended up loving it and relating
to all these characters and it's like
set in this world where
people are fighting against oppression
and they're trying to understand what it
means to be free
and i think that's something we can all
relate to we all have our own like our
own fights and they're all fighting
towards love which to me is the most
important thing the goal yeah yeah and
so i took so many notes while i was
reading it and then it ends on a
cliffhanger so i was like well i have to
figure out what the heck happens next so
there's four books total and i just went
out and bought all three because i was
like i'm gonna love it anyway and yeah
thank you what i love about stranger
reads is that it's not just about
reading it's about connection um and it
just so happens that the author of an
ember in the ashes caught our episode
and reached out so she's actually here
please welcome summits are here
[Applause]
this is so cool
um so it's so great to meet you say hi
to everyone hello hi nice to meet you i
love that you caught the episode and it
was so probably random for you to see it
oh my god it was crazy um i saw it and i
was like is she holding an amber in the
ashes
i just like seeing your kid on tv you
know it's just such a crazy moment and
i think what hit me about it was
you know writing is such an isolated job
you do it alone you eat lots of
chocolate you cry a lot and you're into
your pages with writing songs by the way
yeah so you know um and so to know that
the book is out in the world and people
are reading it it's such a wonderful
feeling and
with what haley said especially haley um
when you said that you felt seen by the
book and you felt represented by the
book
that is why i wrote the book the goal
that was the goal um you know i was a
little kid growing up in the mojave
desert i you know read tons of fantasy
like you know 700 page book in one hand
chocolate bar in the other yeah and um
during that whole time i didn't really
see myself in books right like i just it
was it was the 80s
80s and 90s a fantasy so it was big hair
biceps yeah and very eurocentric you
know very very a male um and i when i
knew when i wrote ember i was like i
want
a brown girl to be front and center in
this book on the cover in the narrative
like that's what it was all about for me
that's so cool i love that it ended up
like happening exactly why you wrote it
it's what affected an individual
um well haley and kevin loves an ember
in the ashes and since this is stranger
reads we wanted everyone to have it so
you're all going home with a copy
and you have you have a new book out and
that's more autobiographical right yes i
do have a new book out um
it took me 15 years to write the new
book um it was a book that required like
a lot of reflection and and self-love
because it was more autobiographical
yeah um it's called all my rage um it
takes place in the i love
the title yes okay yes if you are a 90s
rock fan you know where that title came
from i love it um so it takes place in
the desert it's about two kids uh
growing up
in a place that seems to kind of want to
destroy them and one is noor
she wants to leave and go to college but
she um she has a family member who
doesn't want her to go
and the other is salahuddin and he is
trying to keep afloat a business that
his parents loved and so it's about
these kids and the choices they make
they don't have a lot of support they're
really alone and i felt that as a young
person and so i wanted to put that in a
book and the the heart of that book and
the heart of all of my work even though
all my rage is contemporary it's not
fantasy
but the heart of it is hope ultimately
and hope is sort of what the characters
hold onto an ember and that's what gets
them through four books of me being an
awful evil author and torturing them
yeah and it gets a really good one thank
you and it gets them through through all
my rage too yes that's what got me
through most of my life i think it's
what gets us through life in general i
hope yeah because it you know kind of
does this
well thank you so much for coming on
this is really special so i'm glad that
you you saw the show and i'm glad that
this happened and i'm glad thank you
guys
[Music]
you